promising our woman
is a twisted dark comedy about a woman
named cassie whose life was completely
derailed by
something that happened in her past
she's determined to right the wrongs of
the past
one nice guy at a time
scene between cassie and dean walker is
a pivotal turning point in the movie for
so many reasons
this is the first moment where the
audience finally learns the full story
behind what happened
to nina cassie's best friend while they
were at med school
it's only been alluded to up to this
point she's
on a mission to make sure people
understand the consequences of their
actions
she wants them to just admit their
wrongdoings she wants an apology
she wants to forgive them but that
forgiveness
is you know only only possible if they
confess so this scene starts with cassie
uh in another one of her many disguises
she's waiting outside of girls high
school and she's playing the role
of the incredibly late and lost
makeup artist who's on her way to the
set of a music video for a very popular
boy band
[Music]
see you tomorrow [ __ ] excuse me
excuse me hi me
yeah hi what's up
i'm so sorry but my phone has died and
i'm so late for work do you live around
here do you know the area
i guess why would you tell me how to get
to the castle diner
you know what i'm actually like really
late please i'm supposed to be shooting
this music video another video
yeah i'm a makeup artist and it's my
first time working with these guys and
if i'm late i may as well know oh
my god oh my god are you working for wet
dreams
you didn't see that i know where the
castle diner is don't worry about it
though no way
no way oh my god you're working with
wine trails oh my gosh
are they there right now you need to
calm down i can direct you
sorry no
if i don't direct you how are you gonna
find it
i can't if you tell anyone or you post
about this i will
never work again i swear i won't post
anything i promise
take my phone seriously take it
oh god okay good i'm fine but you have
to be cool about this
no of course i will
whoa you really are a fan i'm obsessed
i have a whole insta dedicated just to
george's dog
crazy coincidence you know
you know what this this is fake
sure sounds like it man
when i wrote this scene it was partly
because i'd been thinking
how easy it is to be a female predator
you know a young woman
is an innocuous presence and only needs
a certain amount of forethought and
planning to
seem credible enough to convince a girl
to get into your car
for cassie's character it was a lot
about
hair makeup and costume as it as it
always is for any character but
especially in this film because she is
changing
her personality her locations and she's
changing the way she dresses for each
occasion
it's very much about a disguise the
high school girls you know the dean's
daughter and her little friends that
were sort of walking
around it was very you know fresh but
sort of like today's
high school girls you put a bit of
mascara on and maybe wear some lip gloss
but not the instagram full beat because
you wanted it to look like
also these people sort of live in
anywhere usa
we start on feet walking and we trap
you know this is like her on our mission
and it's like
so there's a momentum to i'm not sure
the audience is quite sure what's going
on at this moment why she's luring in
this school girl you don't really know
from camera's perspective it's sort of
that first part is to build some kind of
momentum
and curiosity and also a little bit of
fear it ends with a pool focus to like
the closing of the door the locking of
the door
and that's quite like you're like what
is she gonna do
part of what she's doing in sort of
going and meeting these people that were
part of the
kind of in her mind kind of great
conspiracy is
putting down the correct version of
history that you know you've all got
this wrong
that she's not going to live anymore
with people not agreeing with
the truth of the events and within that
she will punish people
you know unless they are prepared to
sort of ask for forgiveness
yes
dean walker is ready if you'd like to go
on through
[Music]
daisy that's me dean walker please sit
my assistant says that you are
interested in resuming med school
that's right may i ask what prompted
your desire to get back to your studies
i guess i couldn't stop thinking about
my time here
yeah that's an extraordinary place
it's an unusual request yes but i left
under unusual circumstances oh
i left because of what happened to nina
hmm
nina fisher you don't remember her
maybe you remember alexander monroe
oh yes alexander monroe he actually just
came back and gave a talk here
oh he's a he's a really nice guy really
smart
are you a friend of his no so you don't
remember the accusations made against al
monroe
i don't he took a girl nina fisher
the one you don't remember back to his
room
where he had sex with her repeatedly and
in front of his friends
while she was too drunk to have any idea
what was going on
she was covered in bruises the next day
handprints
i guess you could say was it reported
yes do you know who nina spoke to
you but you can't remember
so you felt there wasn't
sufficient evidence you said it was too
much of a he said she said situation
well you know we get accusations like
this
all the time one or two a week i'm sorry
i don't remember your friend
nina but i can assure you at that time
that i looked into it thoroughly
his friends were all watching laughing
it's so hard but you know also if she
was drinking
and and maybe couldn't remember
everything
so she shouldn't have been drunk i'm not
saying
that i'm sorry i don't need to sound
critical dean walker i just want to be
clear
none of us want to admit when we've made
ourselves vulnerable
when we've made a bad choice and those
choices those mistakes
can be so damaging and really
regrettable
regrettable yes i mean because what
would you have me do
ruin a young man's life every time we
get an accusation like this
so you're happy to take the boy's word
for it i have to give him the benefit of
the doubt
of course you do because innocent until
proven guilty
no arguing with that no
thank you for your time is your friend
okay
no she's not but al monroe is
you'll be glad to hear he's doing really
well he's getting married
actually so you know i guess he did the
right thing
we have to give these boys the benefit
of the doubt
that's why i know you won't mind that
three hours ago i picked her daughter
amber up from school and
introduced her to the boys who live in
that room now what she is really pretty
huh
she looks a lot older than she is i
don't believe you i noticed they had a
few bottles of vodka
in the room too but i'm sure they'll
take good care of your daughter she
seemed excited actually
oh wait i have her phone
she'll be wanting that later
you're crazy no
tell me what room my daughter is in
right now i told you the same room nina
was in
i told you i don't remember that well
that's a shame
what are you doing she's a young girl
i wonder if she looks so young to those
guys
you better tell me what room she's in
tell me what [ __ ] room she's in
now you sociopath tell me where she is
please tell me
what cassie's looking for from dean
walker is an incredibly straightforward
apology
which doesn't get one then you know she
has to show her
it's painful to cassie because it's
exhausting
to have to go and have the same
conversation every time
i think she really wants to forgive
herself
that's why this is so distressing
because this film really is about
somebody who can't forgive themselves
she is steely-eyed in that scene because
the punishment is fair
and i think to to frighten somebody into
thinking that their daughter is
in a dorm room with some you know um
suspicious
guys feels like a sort of really fair
trade to her in that moment i think
that's where she is in her
kind of mission for justice the way that
cassie's written
in those moments she is absolutely you
know sort of
poker faced and uh and kind of scary in
her lack of empathy but then afterwards
you see the impact on her and you see
that actually she's a human being
it's so it's just true it's just one of
those like truths of life that you
you care more you care differently
when you experience it a little closer
to home
i realized in playing this character and
playing the role that
she's really articulating a point of
view that a lot of people have and maybe
people don't even realize that they have
it's sort of a more uh unconscious or
subconscious point of view
that this dean articulates in the scene
you're right okay is that what you want
to hear
you're right you're right
look how easy it was
i guess you just have to think about it
in the right way
i guess it feels different when it's
someone you love
tell me where my daughter is
relax dean walker do you really think i
would do something like that
luckily i don't have as much faith in
boys as you do amber is sitting in a
diner
waiting for her favorite boy band to
show up for a music video
it's the castle diner if you want to
call and check we should probably call
actually
or she may never figure out they're not
coming she's kind of an idiot
huh gorgeous though
who needs brains they never did a girl
any good
great to see you again dean walker
it's really interesting it's often the
scene of the movie that people have the
most trouble with
that they find it the most difficult
it's just what she's suggesting and
she's doing nothing else
she's literally done nothing that drive
a girl to a diner and made some
suggestions but that is so troubling to
us
it's really really rare to read a script
or read a scene
where i'm genuinely caught off guard
where i'm genuinely surprised and it was
so
clever and it's such amazing payoff i
never approached it
as an act of revenge um
i think it's more that she's living with
such a sense of
injustice i always imagine that she saw
it in kind of almost
childlike terms um
but it wasn't fair and that um you know
it shouldn't have happened to her friend
i remember when i thought about sort of
sticking gum underneath the desk i used
to think about like the girls at school
who did that like
she's stuck in a in a you know she's
been
sort of infantilized by the whole thing
she's still stuck in that time period
we were very deliberate in the kind of
art direction of the scene it's
um everywhere in her office it's only
portraits of men it's all mahogany it's
all ferns it's all dark green
velvet drapes it's the most sort of
masculine environment
we definitely wanted it to be a power
structure
i mean connie represents the man there
had to be that sort of um
you know you're sitting in you're
sitting in the principal's office only
the principal has a
hell of a lot more power and those
colors
a lot of green in there with the wood
it's tied directly
to the log cabin scene i just think that
those are two very authoritative
male moments
that's how it works that's what the
system is
it's interesting because for i think all
of us it was a
different moment from the rest of the
filmmaking
in the most mundane looks in space
she says she kidnapped a kid
and i i think that that's
that's the whole thing is to make it you
know as sort of like innocuous so it
becomes more horrible
the framing really did stand out to me
in this scene it was it felt
i mean with everything you do in this
film there's a deliberate choice behind
it and i think that is also indicative
of
cassie's approach to to this journey
she's on as well
it's it's deliberate we framed dean
walker very central
she had the power this is her office you
don't know what cassie's doing cassie's
kind of on edge i think slightly
and you're not quite sure and halfway
through that scene it flips
like cassie turns the table tells her
she has her daughter
and dean walker all of a sudden is on
the edge of frame
and cassie becomes more central
in that focus and she has the power and
i think that's the sort of psychological
game
you can feel uh the body language of the
dean that is
uh moving back and
we we we played that especially in the
in the profile shot you can
feel our reaction like that and and and
cassie which is very
she's taking over and that moment is
a switch in the scene i both am
horrified i'm sickened and i'm also
giggling and i i think that's the kind
of experience people are really
weirdly like you know not so weirdly but
enjoying about this movie is that
it's kind of it's kind of funny and
delicious and [ __ ] up and weird and
lovable and not like awful it's just
it's so many things and it's such a ride
this is one of those scenes when you
read it in the script
you think first of all you're so excited
to do it but you're also thinking
man i just need to do this justice i
just can't this has to be
it's a hard one not to build up in your
head the writing is so
good and you're so it's so crunchy and
delicious and there's so much going on
you just think
it's such an opportunity and it you know
as we all know it
it's not one that comes up um very often
so i felt that way about this scene
the things that we're talking about in
this film are so common
that people really haven't thought about
them very deeply
and i certainly think in my own life and
in
in you know i think all of our
experiences probably in all sorts of
ways
when people are called out on bad
behavior they
they double down or they give a kind of
like faint apology that's like
i'm sorry you felt this way i'm sorry
that i made you feel you know
that you have these caveats it just
seemed that the
movie is structured as kind of an
old-fashioned bible story like i grew up
with at school
or an allegory it's very simple she goes
on a journey and she teaches people
lessons